près d'une centaine de marches cinq
étages à monter à pied une ascension pas
toujours facile le mari de cette
habitante est malade prendre l'escalier
devenu pour vivre très compliqué et sans
tranquillement il remonte en cédant il
est très fort de ses bras dont qui
remonte en selle d'un de ses bras
moi je peux pas l'aider parce que moi
j'ai de plus ce bâtiment hlm et le sol
du quartier à être équipée d'un
ascenseur et c'est d'ailleurs cet
équipement qui a incité bon nombre de
locataires à s'installer ici
ainsi sur vingt logements c'est seraient
occupés par des personnes âgées ou à
mobilité réduite
mon papa est obligé d'aller habiter
ailleurs parce qu'ils habitent au
cinquième il a des soucis de santé
même pour les autres personnes je suis
pas égaux c'est vraiment une catastrophe
et là on en a ras-le-bol
les responsables de l'opac de saône et
loire en charge de la gestion du
bâtiment n'ont pas souhaité être
interviewé dans un communiqué il se
retranche derrière la procédure de
l'assurance avant d'entamer toute
réparation
s'agissant d'un sinistre nous sommes
contraints par des délais
incompressibles liés aux expertises even
habite au 4e étage en situation de
handicap elle a été relogée
mais elle souhaiterait revenir chez elle
au plus vite l'opac doit prendre ses
responsabilités c'est un bailleur on a
un bail avec eux on paye un loyer ils
doivent s'occuper de ça le problème des
assurances ne nous concerne pas on fait
rendez vous sur rendez-vous des lettres
qui n'aboutissent pas des rendez vous
chacun se renvoie la balle personne
c'est exactement personne n'est au
courant là moi j'attends une semaine et
je la jemaye dans l'événement conseiller
juridique
on est plusieurs à le faire et bien
parce que le pack il nous donne aucune
nouvelle
ça veut rien si eux ils savent pas qui
c'est pour les habitants la galère ne
semble pas sur le point de s'arrêter
selon l'office hlm les réparations
pourraient intervenir en octobre
après la réalisation d'une troisième
expertise